Alright, alright, alright.
Take a full screen!
Okay, okay, like this, right?
Ah, there you go.
Perfect!
That's perfect, right?
Ah, yeah, this is very, very spooky.
I'm scared.
There you go.
Perfect!
I can pick shit up!
Push,
pull, push, pull!
Okay, maybe I need to get my cat out of the way.
Okay.
Can I jump off?
I'm not doing so well.
Oh, oh, wait, you can.
I thought that would be invisible.
Wow.
Can I pick up a shoe?
I can pick up a shoe!
What the
fuck?
There's a fall damage here!
There's a fall damage!
Why?
Why the fuck is there fall damage?
Oh!
It was at this moment that he knew.
He fucked up.
Wait!
Stop!
Can I sprint?
Oh, wait, you can sprint!
Why did no one tell me to sprint here?
I've been fucking walking this entire time.
You can sprint in this game.
Why is it here so tiny?
Look around by using...
Wow!
By using arrow keys?
Oh, shit!
Oh!
I was like...
Oh, shit!
I thought I was...
Don't check under the bed.
Don't check under bed!
Don't check under the bed!
Crying.
Yeah you little bitch.
Yeah, you little bitch.
I thought that is me.
Oh, no!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
Nooo!
I'm not spooked at all.
I'm just fine.
This is too cute.
You're so smart!
Holy shit, look at...